in a rush to deliver fast the milk round
then a majority and then brick sit still
in front but the conservative lead
looking precarious Boris Johnson is
sisse stand a chance of failure which I
think would be absolutely disastrous
economically disastrous physically
disastrous
two more referendums Ronald Scotland one
on the European Union we can't afford
happy to push his message but not taking
questions on trickier matters accused of
politicizing the deaths of terror
victims a difficult few days for the
prime minister as he strains to keep
voters focused on brexit and land a
majority in parliament all the while
this race is tightening
[Applause]
Middlesbrough South the labor target but
really Jeremy Corbyn is a leader in
full-on defense mode little time left to
convince labour leave voters to stick
with him the NHS is calling card we will
protect the NHS we won't do secret deals
with the United States and you have a
government you can trust to tell you the
truth on brexit unlike what we're
getting at the present time but the SNP
is all but wiped out labour in Scotland
and with it any hope of a corbin
majority Nicholas Sargent hopes to add a
few more seats to her tally this time
around from big part to bit part the
minor party squeezed in this race but
Joyce Watson still clinging on to poop
so many people are still making up their
mind and in so many seats it looks like
the result will be very marginal indeed
while this party leaders call him for
change this election is the other guys
worse than me and I do think I do
actually think we need real fundamental
change and political reform you know
we're living in the 21st century with a
nineteenth-century set of institutions
it isn't working anymore
three and a half years on from that EU
referendum this now the second election
called by a conservative prime minister
to try and win a working majority in
that place behind me and resolve brexit
once and for all
but the longer this campaign has gone on
the more Boris Johnson has been taken
off his brexit message and in two areas
he doesn't want to talk about as much
things like the NHS an austerity he's
still comfortably in the lead but the
polls are tightening and number 10 are
worried what once looked like and nailed
on majority is now looking a little less
certain but like it or not it's come
down to a choice between conservative or
labour and as this campaign wraps up mr.
Johnson might find cheer in the
knowledge that he has led this race from
the start who hoped to come away with
the prize
battery piece can use